Hallo Leute, kurz in eigener Sache, betreffend die Tour 2021, hier müssen wir leider Gottes nochmal verschieben, und zwar der Termin in München am 30.10. muss leider verschoben werden, und zwar auf den 11.10.2022.
Die Tickets für die Show behalten ihre Gültigkeit.
Das heißt, der erste Termin unserer Tour wird dann Hannover sein, am 30.11.
Für die Show gibt es auch noch Tickets, also schaut euch um und für die Show gilt die 2G-Regel.
Viel Spaß, wir freuen uns auf euch, bis dann. Podcasts for Ready for Lift-Off. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe, das Podcast über mit mir, Stefan Tietze und dir, Florentin Wild. Entschuldigung, ich bin mir kurz aus der Haut gefahren. Ich bin mir aus der Haut gefahren. Hallo Stefan, danke für die Einladung, vielen Dank, dass ich heute bei dir sein darf, in deinem kleinen Kämmerlein. In meiner Show, Stefan Tietze Show mit Florentin Will als Gast heute. Du siehst gut aus, du hast ja ein Real Bad Bitch T-Shirt an, du bist bereit für diese Sendung, du hast Bock auf Party, Bock auf Feiern, ein paar prikante Fragen, ich bin bereit. Paprikante Fragen stelle ich dir. Paprikante, Paprikante, Paprikante Fragen. Du kannst mich alles fragen, was du willst., Praktikanten-Fragen stelle ich dir heute. Nee, ich bin erleichtert, dass du hier bist überhaupt. Für die Leute da draußen, Leute und ich haben nicht so wahnsinnig viel Kontakt privat. Was daran ja auch liegt, weil wir ja auch jede wöchentlich diese Show hier machen. Und der Unterlassungsklage halt, 70-30 würde ich sagen. Und wegen dieser kleinen Geschichte mit der Unterlassungsklage. So, und dann weiß ich schon, wenn Flonten mich unter der Woche anruft, und es ist nicht, es ist, sagen wir mal, plus, minus zwei Tage entfernt von der Podcast- Aufzeichnung, weiß ich, es ist was im Argen. Ja. Dann bin ich auch ganz ehrlich, da kann ich in wichtigen Meetings sitzen, in wichtigen, was auch immer, Drehbuchbesprechungen oder keine Ahnung wo, ich würde alles unterbrechen, um ranzugehen. Wow, das ist nett von dir, das freut mich. Das meine ich ganz im Ernst. Nee, ich weiß nicht, was so nett ist, weil es ist immer ein wahnsinniger Notfall. Es ist immer ein schlechtes Zeichen, wenn ich anrufe, ja. Es ist immer ein ganz, ganz schlechtes Zeichen. Einmal dachte ich kurz, wir werden kurz vorm Canceln, einmal dachte ich, wir werden beide irgendwie komplett raus, ganz vieles gelöscht, Webseite gelöscht, war auch schon anruft. Ja, stimmt, ja, das ist ja alles schon vorgekommen, das ist nicht, die Angst hat sich bewahrheitet. Aber jetzt ist dein privater Ruin ist es jetzt. Mein privater Ruin, ich bin am Boden, ich bin ruiniert am Ende, finanziell so sozial, das war's. Ich bin durch, ich habe mich diese Woche in finanzielle Notdurft begeben. Sorry, auch kurz dafür, dass ich jetzt einfach diese Information so droppe. Nein, nein, ich bin da völlig offen. Ich glaube, jeder, der mich kennt, privat weiss, dass ich behördlich, finanziell, steuerlich schlecht aufgestellt bin. Angefangen bei, ich gehe mit gebrochenem Zeh zum Arzt und der sagt, sind Sie versichert? Und ich sage, lassen Sie mich noch mal kurz nach Hause fahren und in meinen Unterlagen nachschauen. Um dann bei einer Firma anzurufen, die Künstler Sozialkasse, die nichts anderes weiß mit einer Versicherung zu tun. Ich dann als bei der Rentenversicherung anrufe und sage, ja hallo, ich habe jetzt ein C gebrochen. Und die, ja, okay, gute Besserung. Aber mir gefällt die Idee, in den Dialekt zu wandern. Mir gefällt die Idee, in den bayerischen Dialekt zu wandern. Weil ich habe das Gefühl, dann redet man mit dir langsamer oder so. Also wenn du, weil das wäre meine Theorie, glaube ich, ist es ein bisschen despektierlich, aber ich glaube, so funktioniert nämlich die Welt. Wenn du irgendwo, sagen wir mal, dich doof stellen willst, dann müsste dich die Sachen langsamer erklären. Ja, genau, dann denkt man dir, der hat das halt nicht genau verstanden. Aber in dem Moment, wo du halt mit bayerischem Dialekt anrufst, denkt man ja auch, der kommt vom Dorf, was soll der das denn wissen, wie jetzt hier diese steuerlichen Einzelheiten. Ich glaube, nicht, dass ich so denke, aber dass diese Behörden so denken und sich dann mit dem mehr Zeit nehmen, die sind ein bisschen geduldiger. Ich glaube, bei den Versicherungen ist es genau der gegenteilige Effekt wie bei dir. Wenn die sehen, dass ich anrufe und denke, oh Gott, wir sind Bullshit, irgendwie ein Schwachsinn, der hat sich wieder den Kopf gestossen und ruft bei uns an,
wir haben nichts damit zu tun,
der hat sich ausgesperrt
und ruft jetzt bei der Krankenversicherung an,
die sagt, Entschuldigung, ich habe mich
ausgesperrt, können Sie doch vorbeikommen?
Herr Will, wir sind Ihre
Krankenversicherung, wir haben damit,
also ich, okay, ich rufe Sie einen Schlüsseldienst.
Aber ich verstehe, woher das kommt, weil wenn man
sich bei der Künstlersozialkasse anmeldet, wissen viele von euch nicht, kriegt man erst mal so ein Buch an, wofür die da sind. Niemand liest sich das durch, aber man geht da mit diesem Mindset raus, ja die sind jetzt für mich verantwortlich. Das sind jetzt die, die ich anrufe. Weil ich bin ja Künstler. Also es ist natürlich eine sehr enge Zielgruppe, aber ich weiß nicht, ob wir mal ein paar KSK-Gags rausholen können. Künstler-Sozialkasse, vor allem wenn man sich da anmeldet, muss man angeben, welche Art von Künstler man ist. Und diese Liste ist ein Traum, wo man ankreuzt, welche Art von Künstler man ist. Da gibt es alles von Marionettenspieler, Schattenspielkünstler, Tanztheater, alles Mögliche. Und man sich denkt, ja, irgendjemand kreuzt das mit ernstem Gesicht an. Und irgendwo auf der anderen Seite beim Finanzamt liest jemand dieses Formular mit angekreuzt, ich bin Puppenspieler, Marionettenspieler. Fand ich auch geil, jemanden, den ich kenne, der war in der Schule bei dieser Voraussicht, welche Berufe man gut machen kann, Berufsorientierung, und hat tatsächlich als Vorschlag für den Beruf bekommen Marionettenspiele.
Und das fände ich immer noch großartig.
Das hast du schon mal erzählt und ich finde es immer fantastisch,
wie das zusammenkam, jemals,
was die Kette dieser Ereignisse
war. Ich behaupte immer noch,
dieses Berufsinformationszentrum hat irgendwie,
der Typ hat eine Wette verloren oder sowas, weil
also bei uns kam immer the most generic
shit raus.
Natürlich, normalerweise
kommt da the most obvious shit raus.
Vor allem, die haben doch natürlich Vorlagen.
Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Zahnarztmeister wäre und sage, Leute, wir brauchen mehr Zahnärzte, rufe ich doch als erstes Mal so einen Berufsorientierungstypen an und sage, gib denen mal Zahnarzt. Das ist ja eh die Theorie, dass die Welt nicht funktionieren dürfte, es aber tut, weil Leute Strippen ziehen.
Nicht die Marionettenspieler, ich meine es nicht.
Nee, die, die über den Marionettenspielern stehen, die, die die Marionettenspieler an den Fäden haben. Ja, sprichwörtlich.
Nee, weil ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, es kann ja nicht sein, dass alle die Jobs machen, die sie machen wollen, grob,
und dann eine Gesellschaft quasi entsteht, wo alle Jobs besetzt sind. Das hat damals in unserem Minikamen, ich komme aus Kamen, und wir hatten dieses Simulationsferien-Freizeitspaß-Spektakel-Minikamen. Und da hat es auch nicht funktioniert. Was sich als kommunistische radikale Kommune herausgestellt hat, ihr wurde zerschlagen vom Verfassungsschutz. Ich wünschte, man könnte das in ein Wort fassen, in eine Staatsform, die entstanden ist. Ich würde es Anarchie, blanke Anarchie nennen eher. Sparsgesellschaft. Weil alle wollten zur Sparkasse, weil man da das Minimo, die Minimoneten, die Währung in Minikamen gut klauen konnte. Ach so, es waren alle instant korrupt, oder wie? Es waren alle instant korrupt und so. Eigentlich wollten die meisten zum Bäcker, weil da konnte man halt schon umsonst irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, Zimtschnecken sich reinmampfen oder zur Sparkasse, weil es irgendwie ein guter Job war, der gut bezahlt war. So, aber niemand wollte woanders sein. Niemand wollte in die Bar oder so ein Shit. Bar war damals ja auch Cola, Fanta, Sprite, das ist auch so gegeben und sowas. Aber das hat nicht funktioniert. Und ich denke mir, warum funktioniert es in der echten Welt? Weil wenn es in diesem sehr gut simulierten Planspiel auch nicht funktioniert hat. Ich glaube auch tatsächlich, dass wir, also ich sage jetzt wir für die Unterhaltungsbranche im Allgemeinen, mehr Einfluss darauf haben, als wir denken. Beispiel, ich glaube, nach der Serie Breaking Bad haben sich, sind die Chemiestudenten, haben sich verdreifacht, Leute, die Chemiestudieren wollten, weil alle dachten, oh geil, da mache ich Math, da kann ich Bomben bauen, das ist alles super spannend. Und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, nach Mad Men wollten alle irgendwie in die Werbebranche gehen, weil die das halt cool fanden. Du brauchst nur einen Film oder Serie, die einen gewissen Beruf als cool darstellt. Und schon Scrubs, ich glaube viele Leute in unserem Alter, Medizinstudenten, hat Scrubs eine Rolle gespielt, dass er Medizin studiert oder irgendwie als Krankenschwester oder Pfleger oder sowas arbeiten will. Ich glaube, wir können da mehr machen. Gibt es da mal eine Bachelorarbeit? So eine wissenschaftliche Untersuchung, inwieweit quasi so Peaks in der Berufswahl auf Serien oder Filme, die kurz davor oder eher wahrscheinlich müsste man nur weiter zurückrechnen, weil es ist ja länger her, also du musst ja quasi Kindheit, kindheitsbildende, formende Serien finden. Ich will aber auch eine Bachelorarbeit, wie groß die Enttäuschung dann tatsächlich ist. Ja, das finde ich auch. Die alle sagen, oh geil, ich werde jetzt Hacker, weil ich habe hier Robotman, Mr. Robot gesehen und dann sagen, oh, Hacker sein ist halt auch nur HTTP tippen. Doppelpunkt, schrägstig, schrägstig. Das ist das Einzige, was mich von normalen Menschen unterscheidet. Ich tipp das alles noch aus. Das ist mein schwarzer Hoodie. Ja, genau. Von daher glaube ich, die Enttäuschung ist groß. Also wir müssen jetzt überlegen, welche Berufsgruppen brauchen wir und wie kriegen wir die durch Serien und
Filme cool? Wir brauchen
ja, ich weiß gar nicht, was man braucht.
Ich glaube, so Handwerker
braucht man jetzt wieder ganz viele.
Ich glaube nur, dass in Serien...
Hier, Pumuckl zum Beispiel mit Meister
Eder. Ich glaube, da haben viele gesagt, geil,
so ein ehrlicher... Ich will Kobold werden.
Ja gut, das ist leider
die Kampagne der Handwerkskammer,
das ist da leider ein bisschen ins Leere geschossen,
weil alle Kobold werden wollten.
Aber da kann man sagen, Meister Eder, ich will so einen richtigen,
merke, der Sidekick darf nicht laut zu laut sein.
Ja.
Und zu positiv und zu sympathisch.
Ja, darf nicht zu cool sein, das stimmt schon.
Ich behaupte nur, dass gewisse Berufsgruppen sind in Serien,
und da will ich die Bachelorarbeit zwar, ich will, dass sie entsteht, ich will die aber nicht lesen, weil es, glaube ich, boring ist, aber ich glaube, gewisse Berufsgruppen sind überrepräsentiert. Nämlich sowas wie alles, was mit der Showbranche zu tun hat. Polizisten natürlich, Kommissare. Natürlich Polizisten, Ärzte, halt Anwälte, das sind diese sehr lauten Berufsgruppen, die bei allen auch immer auf den ersten drei Plätzen sind, wenn es darum geht, was sind die logischen nächsten Berufe. Finanzsachen sind ja jetzt auch sehr, sehr aktiv. Gibt es ja auch viele Serien, wie die Serie, die ich gerade schaue, wo ich den Namen sogar vergessen habe. Ich schaue die Serie, ich sehe das Intro mehrmals pro Tag und ich habe einfach den Namen vergessen. Was jetzt nicht für den Namen der Serie spricht, ehrlich gesagt. Auch nicht für die Serie. Wirklich, was ist aus mir geworden? Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin nah am Geist dran. Also ich glaube, Geister sind ja deswegen entstanden als Spuktiere, weil Menschen sich ja im Laufe der Zeit auflösen. Also man wird durchsichtiger, die Leute nehmen einen nicht wahr, Wissen fällt aus einem raus. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich löse mich auf, langsam aber sicher. Ich bin wie in einer Badewanne und ich kann nicht mehr entscheiden, wo hört das Wasser auf und wo fange ich an. Ja, das stimmt, du flüssig auf. Alles so ein Menschbrei. Auch dein linker Arm ist halbtransparent mittlerweile. Ja. Aber ich finde nicht, dass du wirst wie ein Geist, weil Geistern fällt immer sofort ein. Also ich kenne keinen Geist in der ganzen Literatur. Stimmt, es gibt wenig vergessliche Geister. Der dusselig ist. Ja, das stimmt. Die sind schon manchmal ungeschickt. Ist Slimer ein Geist von Ghostbusters? Weiß ich gar nicht. Slimer? Ist das nie ein Pokémon? Nee, wie heißt der Grüne von Ghostbusters? Das tut mir total leid. Ich weiß, ich weiß, dass du... Während des Sprechens richtig hart was ins Auge bekommen. Habe ich dir ins Auge gespuckt aus der Entfernung? Nein, ich weiß, das ist ein Problem mit Aspen, deswegen wollte ich mir jetzt nicht. Meine Kontaktlinse hat sich weirdly gelöst. Dann mach das jetzt. Nee, das Problem hat sich alleine gelöst, irgendwie, erstaunlicherweise. Vielleicht muss ich mir gleich ab und zu ins Auge fassen. Es tut mir leid, dass du es ansehen musst. Woher kommt diese Angst? Haben wir das eigentlich schon mal genau ergründet, woher diese Angst kommt? Knallhart vererbt. Mein Vater ist auch augenphobisch, ähm, aurophobisch. Er ist auch schon mal in Unmacht gefallen, weil seine Augen rot waren und er in den Spiegel geschaut hat. Mir könnte dasselbe passieren. Ich glaube, es hat was mit, weil ich einfach gerne schaue. Ich schaue gerne Sachen an. Du bistirst nicht gerne blind. Genau, ich will mir das nicht vom Teller nehmen lassen und ich habe halt Angst, dass wenn da jemand zu rumrum hat. Ich glaube, es hat auch damit zu tun, dass ich einfach nicht genau check, wie ein Auge funktioniert. Letztens habe ich zum Beispiel den Begriff gehört, dem ist das Auge ausgelaufen und ich dachte mir, lass mich in Ruhe, ich will weg aus dieser Welt, ich will weg aus dieser Welt, ich will einfach, ich will mich updaten, ich will auf einem USB-Stick leben, ich will diesen fucking Körper nicht mehr haben, weg damit, ich will das alles nicht haben. Ich will nicht Körperteile haben, die auslaufen können. Das ist, ach, was heisst das überhaupt? Ist das wie so eine Art Wasserbombe, die Augapfel oder halt wie so eine Art grosse Weintraube und wenn du da drauf drückst, dann spritzt es raus oder was?
Ja, es löst sich einfach auf. Es geht wie so eine, wenn es auch, wenn es irgendwo liegen lässt, abgekoppelt, dann ist es wie so eine Rosine, wird das dann so klein. Ich glaube, Rosine ist ein gutes Beispiel für ein trockenes Auge. Ja, aber würdest du jetzt sofort ja sagen, angenommen man sagt jetzt, große Freiwilligensuche, wir können den ersten Menschen auf ein PC laden, auf einen USB-Stick. Großen, großen, menschengrosen USB-Stick. Da können wir dich draufladen. Ein bisschen wie meine DNA, die ich ja gerade als TXT-Datei noch auf meinem Desktop liegen habe, rumliegen habe, nervt ein bisschen. Aber ich traue mich, das nicht in den Papierkorb zu packen. Wie gross ist die? Für 517 Kilobyte, also extrem überschaubar. Ja, ich glaube, bei komplexeren Menschen ist es vielleicht ein bisschen. Aber ich traue mich nicht, in den Papierkorb zu packen. Wie gross ist die? 517 Kilobyte. Also extrem überschaubar. Ich glaube, bei komplexeren Menschen ist es vielleicht ein bisschen mehr. Bei mir ist es Mitte Kilobit noch. Traue ich mich trotzdem nicht zu löschen. Das liegt im Weg rum immer. Nee, es fühlt sich falsch an, die eigene DNA zu löschen. Das fühlt sich wirklich falsch an. Ja, jetzt habe ich die mal. Aber man sagt jetzt, okay, wir suchen jetzt den einen Menschen, wir wissen nicht, wie es ausgeht, der, vielleicht wurde schon ein Affe, wurde schon hochgeladen in die Cloud. Würdest du dich melden und sagen, ja, bin dabei. Ich müsste die Bedingungen wissen, wenn ich mich hochlade, verschwinde ich dann als Mensch oder existiere ich weiterhin als Mensch? Nein, als Mensch existierte den Körper. Ich bin auch nur hochgeladen. Du bist nur hochgeladen. Also Backup. Du hast ein Backup, aber du hast keine Hardware mehr. Das heißt, ich existiere ja immer noch, es gibt mich dann zweimal. Einmal als Software, einmal als ... Bei dem Prozess gehst du als Mensch drauf. Ach so. Es kann dich nicht zweimal geben. Ja, dann ist ja die Frage, wann genau macht man das Backup. Dann ist ja die Frage, kann ich dann noch weiter Sachen lernen, oder bin ich dann für immer so? Nee, du bist wie du jetzt bist, nur ohne deinen Körper. Ja, sofort. Würdest du sofort machen. Du hast keine Beziehung zu deinem Körper, du kannst keinen Sex mehr haben. Cloud ist okay, aber jetzt nicht USB-Stick, weil ich habe schon USB-Sticks verloren, das wäre lame. Cloud, ja klar, natürlich, dann kommst du hierher mit den USB-Stick auf. Kommst du hierher mit Innenvermindungen, ich bin in der Cloud, ich nehme auf, ich bin bereit, ich kann nicht wieder zu spät kommen. Nee, aber du vergisst gerade, da zieht er die Frage ab. Es gibt doch 270 Podcast-Folgen mit mir, man kann da doch einen Stimmcomputer bauen, das ist doch locker, ich sag doch immer dasselbe. Das stimmt, aber das geht bestimmt, ja, ja, da müssen wir einen Stimmcomputer bauen, aber du vergisst gerade alles, du kannst nicht mehr fühlen, du kannst nicht mehr riechen, nicht mehr schmecken, du hast keinen Hunger mehr, du hast keinen Bock mehr was zu essen. Super perfekt. Grossartig. Du kannst keinen Sex mehr haben. Ja. Das wird mir fehlen, glaube ich. Mensch, das wird mir echt, das wird mir abgehen. Das ist krass, ne? Das ist echt das. Ne, lassen wir, ne? Lieber rumficken, ne? Das ist mir schon auch wichtig. Also auch mit drum und dran. Und also alles mache ich ja. Also mit, also, also. Ja, stimmt. Unsere Top-5-Sechstellungen. Okay. Aber angenommen, kann man denn eine Rosine wieder rückgängig machen zur Weintraube? Oder ist es eine Einbahnstrasse? Du hast es gerade behauptet, eine Rosine sei eine trockene Weintraube. Kann ich denn dann auch einfach eine Weintraube wieder ins Wasser werfen? Wir haben jetzt übrigens eine Protokollistin hier, die jemand mitschreibt, wie eine sehr leisen Schreibmaschine. Da sitzt sie im Hintergrund und schreibt alles mit. Ja, habe ich behauptet, ich glaube, es geht rückgängig, viel gießen. Kann man denn eine Rosine wieder wachgießen sozusagen? Ich glaube schon. Aber auch hier die Frage, was ist abhandengekommen? Es wird ja nur getrocknet. Das ist ja nur Wasser, was fehlt. Alles andere kann ja nicht in die Atmosphäre entschwinden. Nehmt mal eine Packung Weintrauben und tut die mal in Wasser und schaut, ob ihr dann wieder saftige Weintrauben daraus bekommt. Das klingt wie das langweiligste Science-Experiment der ganzen Welt, ey. In Beiwissenschaft geht es nicht darum, aufregend zu sein, sondern um Dinge zu lernen. Was du nicht verstehst, ist, wir konkurrieren ja gerade hier im Internet mit sehr vielen anderen spannenden Wissenschaftsvideos und sowas. Ich sehe an meinem Tag, pro Tag sehe ich hundert spannende Wissenschaftsexperimente. Dann stelle ich mir gerade vor, ich höre diesen Podcast, wo die mir raten, allen Ernstes, ich soll Rosinen das Wasser packen. Ich würde das ausmachen und nie wieder anmachen. Ich glaube, man lernt mehr aus einem billigen Experiment, das man selber durchgeführt hat, als irgendwie ein fancy Experiment in CERN, von dem man nur liest. Ich glaube, Wissenschaft muss man auch Hand anlegen. Einfach sagen, ich nehme zehn Rosinen in unterschiedlich warmes Wasser, und das eine ist gefriere ich, unter anderem ist ein bisschen Salz drin. Wie unterscheidet sich das? Ich habe jetzt keinen Bock drauf. Ich habe eher Bock drauf, die Elementar-Gravitationswellen zu messen. Wie kann ich das dann privat machen? Zuhause. Wie kann ich zuhause mit einem Zettel und Papier und so einem Pappbecher und diese ganzen Sachen, die Neil, unser großer Künstler, immer von Artitek hatte, wie kann ich damit Gravitationswellen messen? Das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. So ein Video Higgs-Boson für Kinder. Wie weise ich das Higgs-Boson nach? Und dann wirklich mit so einem Post-it-Note und so einem Nilpferd-Radiergummi. So handelsüblichen Sachen, die man so hat. So viele Stabilo-Sachen. Quantenphysik für zu Hause. Genau. Aber dann ist das Video auch wirklich so acht Stunden lang. Genau, man muss sich die ganzen Formeln herleiten. Aber genauso süss. Ja, richtig niedlich. Die Musik nervt irgendwann, weil die nur gelubt ist, aber es ist genauso süss mit so Dingen, die man so handelsüblichen Schreibwarenläden kaufen kann. Am Ende weist du halt das Higgs-Boson nach. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Wissenschaft für zu Hause. Finde ich gut. Pröbe das doch einfach mal aus. Und vor allem, ich glaube, viele wissenschaftliche Durchbrüche wurden nicht gemacht,
weil Leute gesagt haben, das ist doch langweilig.
Wie du jetzt gesagt hast, ist doch langweilig
Rosine in Wasser. Vielleicht kommt was
richtig Geiles bei raus, vielleicht kann man da gute,
vielleicht kann man Strom,
entsteht dadurch Strom oder irgendwie sowas, wer weiß.
Übrigens, gar nicht so weit weg, von einigen
Folgen hatten wir behauptet,
dass die Wissenschaft,
genau wie wir gerade gesagt haben, wahrscheinlich keine Fortschritte macht, weil man die so beschreute Sache nicht ausprobiert. Wie mal Zimt in den Tank reinmachen. Das war unsere, wir hatten das Zimt-Phänomen gemacht. Guck mal, ob Zimt nicht die Lösung ist. Müssen wir uns wieder entschuldigen? Nee, im Gegenteil, wir waren ganz knapp davor. Es war nicht Zimt, es war Zucker. Aber ein Esslöffel. Aber wir waren im Milchreisbereich. Also im Milchreis-Kontext waren wir sehr, sehr nah dran. Wir waren im Trepp-Slay-Milchreis-Kontext so nah dran. Moment mal, kann man mit Zucker Auto fahren? Nein, aber es gab so ein großes Ladeproblem bei großen Akkus. Und das wurde gelöst mit einem Esslöffel Zucker. Na, guckt mal. Und ich dachte mir, ja, haben die vielleicht das Podcast so gehört. Ja. Und Zimt hat vielleicht nicht funktioniert. Und was ist als nächstes? Und sich vom Alphabet nach oben gegangen ist. Zucker. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, oft sind so langweilige Sachen auch einfach die Lösung. Wir kennen von vielen Sachen noch nicht wirklich, was die können. Das meinten wir ja. Macht mal den Zimtversuch. Versucht mal offensichtliche Dinge. Geht mal all in. Macht mal offensichtliche Dinge. Wenn ihr kein Waschmittel zu Hause habt und trotzdem eure Kleidung waschen wollt, nehmt Zimt. Vielleicht klappt das ja. Vielleicht klappt das ja richtig gut oder eure Waschmaschine geht kaputt. Aber eins von beiden, das ist natürlich schwer dem Klempner zu erklären, der sagt, ich hab jetzt, also ich weiß auch nicht, was da falsch ist. Ir geht die nicht mehr. Und dann ruckelt er so eine Schublade, müssen Sie die aufmachen? Ja, macht die so auf und dann so. Warum riecht sie das? Kann es sein, dass sie mit Zimt gewaschen haben? Ach ja, nein. Jetzt wo sie es vielleicht da, aber daran liegt das doch nicht, oder? Ach ja. Ich glaube, ich denke, dass Salz wiederum das Gegenteil ist, weil das wird für zu viele Sachen benutzt. Für so Rotweinflecken erstmal Salz drauf. Ja. Schnecken im Garten erstmal Salz drauf. Erstmal Salz drauf. Ist diese makabere. Es schmeckt nicht, Salz drauf. Ja. Vampir, Salz, Salzkreis, Nacktschnecke, ja, stimmt schon, überall Salz. Ja, das ist das Problem, wenn man jetzt irgendwie auf Salz alles outgesourst. Mal Zimt, mal Zucker. Ja, mal irgendwie Koriander, Nelken oder irgendwie so ein Kram. Finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Koriander melken? Ja. Okay. Koriander melken, ist das dein Wahlspruch jetzt für die Wahl? Koriander melken? Unsere Partei schneidet übrigens ganz schlecht ab, also ich weiß nicht, ihr hört die Folge vielleicht Samstag oder Sonntag, also direkt zur Wahl, geht wählen, haut eure Stimme raus.
Hast du schon gewählt? Ich habe schon gewählt, ich habe schon meine Briefwahlunterlagen abgegeben, aber ich habe immer Angst, dass, also, vielleicht ist das eine unbegründete Angst, aber irgendwie bei der Briefwahl denke ich mir, weil ich bringe das dann immer zu so einem Kiosk und der guckt mich immer an mit dem Blick, ja der kauft eh nie was, der gibt hier immer nur seine Briefe ab. Wo die ja auch was von haben. Weiß ich nicht, weiß ich nicht. Was glaubst du, warum die sonst das machen, die machen das nicht aus Goodwill. Habe ich mir auch überlegt, vielleicht haben die so einen Deal wie, ihr nehmt bei uns die Postart an, dafür kann man da euch, weil wenn du dein Paket abholst bei so einem Kiosk, dann kaufst du ja vielleicht auch was. Das heißt, der Kioskbesitzer sagt, hey, liebe Post, ich will bei euch die Post empfangen, dafür kriege ich Leute oder irgendwie sowas in die Richtung. Es gibt doch oft solche Dienste. Die Welt ist wie so in Watte gehüllt, einfach alle machen aus Spaß Dinge in der Hoffnung, vielleicht kauft ihr was, vielleicht nicht, ich nehme trotzdem gerne dieses ganze Pak Pakete an. Nein, die kriegen einen Haufen Cash. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich zu wenig. Weiß ich nicht, weiß ich nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall habe ich meine Brieffalte abgelegt und der legt das dann halt einfach immer so neben sich. Wo ich eigentlich immer gerne hätte, so, ich will jetzt so offiziell, dass der das in so einem Tresor versiegelt, in so einem Tresor oder am besten noch in so einem Luftdruckschlauch, in so ein Röhrensystem steckt. Aber nein, das liegt da, wo ich mir denke, nichts beweist, dass der das nicht einfach wegschmeißt. Das ist der Leute Wahlmann. Ja, immer so, wenn Logies aufmacht. Ja. Vor allem diese Menschen, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber die telefonieren immer. Und ich frage mich. Telefonieren die miteinander eigentlich, dass sie alle mit anderen Kioskbesitzern telefonieren? Ja, und nicht nur die, sondern auch Taxifahrer telefonieren sehr häufig. Was ist das für ein Anruf? Nee, vor allem, was ich mich mal frage, es ist nämlich dieses Gespräch, in etwa in dieser Lautstärke. Und dann oft witnesse ich nur den Teil des Anrufs, wo nicht viel gesprochen wird. Redet die Person auf der anderen Leitung die ganze Zeit oder ist es da ähnlich Low Energy? Und was sind das für Gespräche und worum geht es da? Oder ist es nicht eher so ein, ah, wir wollen nicht alleine sein, wir lassen den ganzen Tag mal laufen und reden halt ab und zu, weil es zwei Freunde sind vielleicht, die beide einen Kiosk haben oder der eine ist Taxifahrer, der andere ist Kioskbesitzer oder sowas. Ich glaube, es ist ein riesengroßer Call, wo alle Kioskbesitzer und alle Taxifahrer gleichzeitig drin sind. Deswegen redet jeder einzelne auch so wenig, weil da sind 3000 Teilnehmer drin. Und jeder redet mal und dann stimmen die über Sachen ab, irgendwie so, wie unangenehm soll das Radio sein im Taxi, kriegen wir es noch irgendwie noch unangenehmer hin irgendwie, können wir noch obskurere politische Ansichten vertreten und in der Taxifahrt ausdrücken, sowas wird dann diskutiert. Wie bescheuert können wir sein, um den Fahrgast möglichst eine unangenehme Fahrt zu bereiten, sowas, glaube ich, wird da konstant diskutiert. Mir gefällt auch dieser neue Trend, dass man mich fragt, wo das ist, wenn ich in Taxi steige und sage, bin ich in einer fremden Stadt zum Beispiel, in Berlin oder so und sage, ich muss zu diesem Hotel und dann drehen sich um und sagen, wo ist es denn? Und ich sage, ich habe keine Ahnung. Das ist mein Ziel, ich bin in dieser fremden Stadt,
ich habe Angst, ich habe Angst mit Ihnen.
Generell gerade bin ich in einem State of Fear und ich möchte, dass Sie mich
da hinbringen. Und dann kommt
diese Frage, warum,
wo ist es denn? Und ich, dann muss ich
das bei, muss ich jetzt navigieren,
muss ich jetzt bei Google Maps eingeben, Sie sind da Taxifahrer.
Ja, ich fühle mich aber trotzdem immer selber schuldig.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie im Supermarkt, wenn man irgend so ein Obst kauft und dann an der Kasse dann gefragt wird, wissen Sie, was das ist? Und ich denke immer so, wenn ich jetzt Nein sage, stelle ich da, dass ich Dinge kaufe, von denen ich nicht mal weiß, was es sind. Ja. Aber so ist es. Ich hole mir das irgendwie und ich weiss nicht, äh, ab, ab, ab, kurs, ich weiss es nicht genau.
Und es ist, weiss der Gter, kauft der willkürliche Dinge, nimmt bunte Sachen aus den Regalen und kauft die einfach. Die im schönsten aussehen. Aber es ist wirklich so einfach, wissen die, was es kostet? Es ist eine generelle Angst, wenn er auch vor Rückfragen einfach. Ja, keine Rückfragen. Aber bei Taxifahrern finde ich das so bezeichnend, weil dann kann ich ja auch selber fahren.
Mach ja manchmal, nehme mir mal ein Car-to-go.
Ja, kann man dann sagen, lassen Sie mich fahren?
Dass man einfach sagt, jetzt setzen Sie sich mal nach hinten und ich fahre.
Ja, ich verstehe es nicht, weil die haben auch selber Navigationssysteme, aber die benutzen sie ja nicht.
Auch Stolz vielleicht.
Aber warum erfordert das mehr Stolz, als mich zu fragen, wo das denn ist? Ich werde auch immer gefragt, wollen wir da lang fahren oder da lang fahren? Und ich denke mir, keine Ahnung, warum es überhaupt eine Frage ist, die wahrscheinlich will ich den schnellsten Weg. Auch diese Rückfragen, ah, ich würde es mal auf, ah, das ist dann über die Reichenbachler und dann in die Schneesinger. Ja, ja, ja, das. Und dann haben sie nur verarscht. Das führt nämlich gar nicht dahin.
Okay, sie haben gewonnen. Sie haben gewonnen. Sie können das besser als ich. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Direkt aufgeben, das ist meine soziale Taktik.
Nee, ist unangenehm, aber kommt häufig vor.
Und bei mir ist jetzt auch immer die grosse Angst, weil, wie gesagt, ich bin ja in massiven finanziellen Schwierigkeiten gerade und ich habe wirklich meine größte Angst gelernt, ist, du stehst an der Supermarktkasse, hast das Band vollgepackt, drei Bottiche Mr. Max 15 Kilo Getränk und alles wird durchgepiept und dann wird eine Karte abgewiesen und du hast kein Bargeld dabei. Ich hätte dann Warhead vergessen, ich hätte gar nicht mein Pommes zu Hause vergessen, aber schon selbstbewusst mit Mr. Max das Band vollgepackt und ich bin auch ein sehr arroganter Mensch, also so im Alltag, ich bin dann auch so ungeduldig, wenn die davor zu lange brauchen, ein bisschen Tü und sowas. So, und dann aus diesem Default-Hochstatus wird man halt einfach, man wird da rausgeholt und auf den Boden 20 Stocken tiefer geworfen, weil Portemonnaie vergessen. So, und dann steht man dann da mit seiner Arroganz. Ja, das ist das Schlimmste, weil dann ist auch so die Frage, und dann bei mir wäre dann wirklich die Frage, wenn dann der Kassierer fragt, okay, wollen Sie noch schnell Geld abheben? Und ich, nee, ich bin ruiniert. Ruiniert, ich habe kein Geld mehr. Okay, dann, tschau, schönen Tag, ja, tschau, ich lasse meine Nahrungsmittel, die ich zum Überleben brauche, by the way, lasse ich jetzt hier bei Ihnen und ich gehe alleine wieder nach Hause. Ciao, macht's gut, Leute, ich bin raus. Das war's von mir. Das war's von mir, halbe Stunde durch den Garten gelaufen, Sachen rausgesucht, die bleiben jetzt hier liegen und ich hab Hunger. Ciao, macht's gut, ich bin raus. Vor allem sollte man die dann auch nehmen und wieder einsortieren. Ich weiß nicht, was die in den Sinn kommt. Ja, das biete ich immer an, ich sage, ich räume das wieder. Also nein, nein. Und ich kaufe hauptsächlich tiefgefrorene Erbsen und die liegen dann da. Rumm. Ganz trauriger Anblick auch. Ganz, ganz trauriger Anblick. Und die schreien alle, die Erbsen, weil sie nicht gekauft werden, sondern jetzt langsam dahins schmilzen. Vor allem, ich kaufe halt lauter überteuerten Scheiß. Ich kaufe irgendwie den Superman Toaster, ich kaufe irgendwie den Köln, die super hardcore vermarketingten Produkte, wo man weiß, die kosten doppelt so viel, wie sie wert sind, wo man sich auch fragt, okay, wenn du kein Geld auf dem Konto hast, ist das wirklich das, wofür man das Geld aufgeben soll? Warum Mr. Max in the first place? Und nicht einfach nur Küchenpapier, Klopapier und Wasser. Nimm die Basics. Mischt man sich da ein Mittagessen draus. Ich meine, wir alle wissen, wir haben alle schon in schweren Zeiten einfach mal Küchenrolle mit Wasser gegessen. Man muss da manchmal durch. Zellulose ist nahrhaft. Ja, warum nicht? Ja, aber das ist ein Problem. Aber ich habe dann, bin ich dann, die müssen gelagert für mich an der Kasse, ich bin nach Hause gegangen, habe mein Portemonnaie geholt, nur um dann festzustellen, auf dem Weg hin, ah, ich hätte einfach mal ein Handy zahlen können. Naja, Apple Pay. Ja, well, nee, so weit fortgeschrieben bin ich nicht. Ich habe immer noch die Papierzettel. Du hast deinen pinken Warnumschlag abgegeben im Kiosk und er wurde einfach hingelegt. Oder einfach hingelegt. Warum macht er denn nicht einfach auf und guckt, was dieser Idiot gewählt hat? Denke ich mir auch, könnte man ja machen, aufmachen und wenn eine Partei, ich eine Partei gewählt habe, die der Person nicht gefällt, ich kann die auch gar nicht einschätzen, wird einfach zerrissen, aber wo ich mich frage, wie viele, wie viel Wahlbetrug muss stattfinden, damit die Wahl wiederholt wird, also kann ich jetzt sagen, also ich als Kioskbesitzer zerreiss zwei und sag dann, wenn mir das Ergebnis der Wahl nicht gefällt, sagt, hier, ich gestehe, ich habe zwei Wahlzettel zerrissen, wir müssen eine Nummer wählen.
Und das mache ich so lange, bis die Partei gewinnt,
die ich gewinnen sehen will.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass zwei
Stimmen... Was ist der Mindest...
Wie viele Stimmen müssen mindestens betrogen worden
sein, damit man sagt, machen wir
nochmal neu. Das ist eine Frage, die andere Frage, was ist
die knappste Wahl der Geschichte?
Ja. So die, wo wirklich
es auf zwei Stimmen angekommen wäre. War das nicht bei Bush irgendwie so, dass es mal super knapp war irgendwie? Aber so die knappste Wahl, wo es so um zehn Stimmen ging, in so einem millionenschweren Wahlsystem. War das nicht sogar, ich glaube, das ist nur eine Urban Legend, aber irgendwo wo ein Politiker mit einer Stimme verloren hat und es sich herausgestellt hat, dass er selber nicht gewählt hat. Aber ist vielleicht auch eine Simpsons-Volge. Eine lustige Simpsons-Volge. War es vielleicht auch ein lustiger Reddit-Post oder so ein Bild mit einem lustigen Text. Keine Ahnung. Kann niemand nachvollziehen. Niemand. Das weiss niemand mehr. Niemand einfach. Nee, genau. Aber das kann natürlich sein. Ich glaube nicht, dass der eine Kitas-Besitzer die Chance hat und so. Ich habe es direkt in den Briefkasten geworfen. Das gibt es nämlich auch. Das sind diese gelben Dinger, die quasi genau das sind, wonach du gesucht hast gerade. Du nimmst ja dann einen Brief raus und steckst einen rein, oder wie? Oder wie funktioniert das? Ich stecke das da rein. Und nimmst einen raus dann wieder stattdessen. Ich verstehe nicht, woher das jetzt kommt. Aber dann sind ja immer mehr drin. Du kannst einfach, Flontien, die stehen da rum und du kannst deine Briefe reinwerfen.
Ja, Stefan, aber wenn da jeder einen Brief reintut, dann sind die ja
irgendwann voll. Flotin, dafür werden die gelehrt.
Der kommt nämlich dann
einmal am Tag, manchmal sogar zweimal am Tag.
Stefan, hör mir zu, was ist, wenn
die voll sind, bevor die gelehrt sind?
Ich glaube, das passiert nicht.
Nein, du musst immer, jeder
tut einen Brief rein und einen raus.
Sonst funktioniert das nicht. Warum ist denn der Brief, den du reinwirfst, wichtiger als den, den du rausnimmst? Naja, immer der, der als letztes reingeworfen wird, wird auch tatsächlich überliefert, alle anderen nicht. Das heißt, man müsste eigentlich, um sicherzugehen, dass sein Brief ankommt, den ganzen Tag da stehen bleiben und den Leuten aus der Hand reißen, wenn die rausgeholt haben. So kenne ich das System. Also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich hier Recht habe. Ja, kann sein. Sehr, sehr sicher. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, deswegen ... Ich bin mir sehr, sehr sicher. Okay. Aber, nee, kann schon sein. Wie gesagt, ich bin ... Also alles offen, aber ich bin mir extrem sicher, dass ich voll und ganz in jeder Hinsicht Recht habe und du völlig falsch liegst. Aber wir wissen nicht, wie es ist. Wie sicher bist du dir generell bei Gesprächen? Bei mir ist immer, also meine Körperhaltung und alles sagt, sehr sicher, mein Kopf sei die ganze Zeit, oder vielleicht auch nicht, oder es war das exakte Gegenteil von dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Ich habe kaum Erinnerungen mehr an diese Doku. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich die geschaut habe, oder ob ich die nicht geschaut habe, sondern Freunde habe mir erzählt, wie die Doku war und hat mir das vielleicht falsch erzählt, oder war es ein Gag. Ja, ich versuche immer nach Gesprächen, also so, keine Ahnung, ich war jetzt auf einer Hochzeit, habe mich mit Leuten unterhalten, halt über Politik, Religion, Wissenschaft und versuche dann aber zwei Tage nach der Hochzeit nochmal eine Follow-up-Nachricht zu schreiben und sagen, du, folgende Dinge habe ich falsch gesagt, es war nicht 40 Prozent, sondern zwei. Es war nicht Sudan, sondern Iran. Sorry. Wo man jetzt auch so steht, der auf sich fragt, worüber habt ihr die ganze Zeit gesprochen? Es war nicht Libyen, sondern Lubien. Es war nicht Chewbacca, sondern Ron. Es war nicht Beirut, sondern Beirut. Und einfach so eine Liste an Korrekturen, um einfach der Person zu bedeuten, so ich habe alles, quasi alles falsch gesagt, der Film hieß anders, das Album hieß anders, also alles falsch, um einfach das nochmal einzuordnen. Das war Schreck. Als du mich gefragt hast, was mein Lieblingsfilm war,
habe ich Schiner Sisse gesagt, Korrektur, Schreck.
Um das nochmal klarzustellen, das ist mir wichtig. Um dann zwei Tage später nochmal eine Foto-Opliste zu schreiben. Korrektur, Shrek 2. Aber da versuche ich dann auch immer nochmal zu korrigieren, weil ich glaube, jeder Redner redet Bullshit. Die Frage ist nur, wer kann danach noch korrigieren und sagen, das war falsch. Tatsächlich, wenn ich manchmal Zeitungen in der Hand habe, selten, ich lese immer nur die Korrekturen. Das finde ich das einzige Interessante ist, Leute, wir haben richtig Scheiße gebaut. Wir haben behauptet, der Typ ist super korrupt und hat Geld hinterzogen. Dabei haben wir einfach nicht genau verstanden, wie das funktioniert und das ist alles rechtens und sorry.
Ich glaube aber auch, alle Menschen sind labernd Quatsch und alle Menschen bullshitten sich gleich durch die Welt, habe ich immer das Gefühl.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass niemand so richtig gut in seinem Job ist, so alle sind so wie ich und tun immer so, als würden sie lange arbeiten, aber haben es eigentlich dann, was sie mussten, irgendwie in zwei Stunden runtergeschrieben und den Rest bei Reddit rumgehangen und so. Weißt du, wie ich meine? Also alle sind ja so, dass sie donnerstags denken, ach, jetzt ist ja auch schon Donnerstag, morgen ist noch Freitag, dann arbeite ich noch kurz was weg und so, dann habe ich aber auch um 16 Uhr schon diesen Termin, von dem ich niemandem erzählt habe, aber ich fülle bestimmt mal keinen auf, wenn ich schon gehe. Jeder Bullshit ist ja auch ein bisschen so durch die Arbeitswelt durch. Wobei ich mittlerweile fast das Gefühl habe, man wirkt klüger, wenn man sagt, ich weiß es nicht oder ich möchte dazu nicht sagen, weil mir ist es echt aufgefallen, es ist ja dieser klassische Dunning-Kruger-Effekt, je kompetenter Leute sind, desto geringer schätzen sie ihre Kompetenz ein, wollen also immer weniger sagen, weil sie das gesamte Fail umliegen. Und weil mittlerweile hier den Wikipedia-Artikel von Dunning-Kruger durchgelesen hat, bist du der Meinung, wenn man jetzt sagt, ich weiß es nicht, sagen alle ein Genie. Genau, weil ich habe letztens mit einer Biologin gesprochen und die schreibt ihre Doktorarbeit über das Thema Wie passen sich Pflanzen an Hitze an? Was passiert in Pflanzen, wenn sie Hitze ausgesetzt sind? Das ist Thema ihrer Doktorarbeit.
Und da ich gerade den aktuellen Försterstreit verfolge, ich weiß nicht, ob du den aktuellen Försterstreit im Kopf hast gerade, es gibt den grossen Försterstreit. Es war mir nicht gewahr. Es gibt den grossen Försterstreit, und zwar einmal gibt es die Förster, die sagen, jetzt mit dem Klimawandel, es wird immer heißer, unsere Wälder halten das nicht aus, wir müssen neue Baumtypen importieren aus Spanien, Italien, die die Hitzeresistente, mehr an Hitze gewohnt sind, die müssen wir in unsere deutschen Wälder integrieren. Und dann gibt es die andere Seite des Försterstreites, die sagt, nein, unsere deutschen Wälder können das auch mit den hiesigen Sorten überleben, wenn man die vernünftig Mischwälder macht und so und das einfach vernünftiges Förstertum macht, dann braucht man nichts zu importieren. Auf der zweiten Seite ist Peter Wohlleben mein Lieblingsförster, deswegen verfolge ich diesen Försterstreit gerade so ein bisschen. Wie hitzig ist denn dieser Streit? Anders gefragt, wenn ich jetzt zwei verschiedene Förstertypen in einen Raum sperre und die Tür zumache, was passiert dann? Ja, man muss sagen, Försterstreit sind nicht so intensiv, wie man es jetzt vielleicht erwarten würde. Die kämpfen mit grünen Daumen. Die kämpfen mit grünen Daumen, die pflanzen erstmal viel an und lassen das dann langsam wachsen. Und lassen dann die Pflanzen, die Pflanzen so schief an, damit die dem anderen so ins Gesicht pflanzen. Das dauert halt neun Jahre, bis das gewachsen ist. Also dieser Streit wird milde geführt. Im Schatten. Es ist ein Streit im Schatten. Sagen wir mal so. Im Schatten entspannt. Das was ein Förster. Ja, genau. Surfer, ich weiß nicht. Über den großen Surferstreit müssen wir auch gleich noch reden. Da will ich gar nicht drüber sprechen. Da schlagen die Wellen hoch. Da will ich nicht drüber sprechen. Da schlagen die Wellen richtig hoch. Das heißt, es gibt diesen First-Streit zwischen, sollen wir ausländische Baumsorten importieren, ja oder nein? Und ich habe diese Biologin gefragt, wo stehst du in diesem Konflikt? Man erinnert sich, sie schreibt in der Doktorarbeit über, wie reagieren Pflanzen in der Hitze. Und sie hat gesagt, da möchte ich nichts dazu sagen, da kenne ich mich nicht gut aus. Wo ich mir dachte, du schreibst eine Doktorarbeit über ein so extrem ähnliches Thema. Aber da war ich echt beeindruckt, weil ich mir dachte, ja, die weiss genau, wie viel sie nicht weiss. Und die weiss auch, das ist so ein komplexes Thema. Es reicht, dass ich das Nachbarthema bearbeite und ich kann schon über das nächste Thema nichts mehr sagen. Wo ich mir dachte, wow, vielleicht sollte ich das auch häufiger machen, dass man einfach sagt, da kann ich mich nicht genug aus, da habe ich zu wenig Studien gelesen, da möchte ich nichts dazu sagen. Aber auch guter, also Respekt an dich, dass sie dich für so kompetent hält, dass sie dir gesagt, dass sie sich überlegt hat, nee, ich bin jetzt ehrlich zu diesem Menschen. Ach so, dass sie sich nicht einfach durchbullshit. Nee, genau, weil ich behaupte nämlich, dass solche Leute, die so clever sind, dass sie wissen, darüber habe ich keine Ahnung, normalerweise in sozialen Occasions dann einfach die, ich rede gerade eh mit jemandem, der keine Ahnung davon hat und diese Frage mehr oder weniger als Höflichkeit stellt, da kann jemand Bullshit erzählen, so was ich glaube grob. Ja, stimmt schon. Ich bin gespannt, wie sich dieser Försterstreit entwickelt, vielleicht werden wir das Ende noch erleben im grossen Försterkrieg. Wer weiss, vielleicht entwickelt sich der Streit wirklich weiter zu einem handfesten Konflikt. Wollen wir dem hier mal ein Forum bieten? Gerne. Dass wir zwei Förster, aber wir verraten beiden nicht, dass dieser andere führende Förster dabei ist. Genau, wir laden sie separat ein, Peter Wohlleben und ein Vertreter der ImportförFirster. Und dann einfach kommen die beide in den Raum und schauen sich so an mit, nein, Peter! Aber im Hintergrund sind schon die Türen schlossgefallen, abgeschlossen worden. Sauerstoff wird abgesaugt, Mikrofonen gehen an, ihr habt zehn Minuten, in zehn Minuten ist der Sauerstoff im Raum leer, ihr habt jetzt zehn Minuten Zeit, euren Streit zu klären, let's go! Ich glaube nicht, die werden dann nicht tot umfallen, die werden bis dahin langsam müde und schon einschlafen, ich weiß nicht, ob das eine gute Idee ist, das abziehen. Naja. Ja, okay. Dann in zehn Minuten wird langsam der Sauerstoff abgepumpt. Aber wo du gerade meinst, wäre das was. Weil ich finde, so Gespräche in unserem Alter mit Leuten oder sagen wir mal auch bei bei Erwachsenen, diese Gespräche auf Hochzeit, wie du gerade meintest, das ist doch alles Quatsch.
Also wenn ich jetzt eine Frage stelle wie, und wo studierst du gerade, ist doch nur, ja, ich halte die Stille gerade nicht aus. Ja.
Das ist doch kein wirkliches Interesse. Das ist mir nämlich dann aufgefallen, als ich gestern durch die Innenstadt in Köln gelaufen bin und dann hat ein kleines Kind eine erwachsene Frau gefragt, irgendwie haben sich zwei alte Freundinnen getroffen und so, beide erwachsen und eine hatte dann ihren Sohn dabei und der Sohn hat gefragt, es war in Köln, er hat gesagt, wir gehen häufig zum Brüsseler Platz, geht ihr da auch häufig hin? Und ich fand das so eine schöne Frage, also belanglose Kackfrage, die auch von mir kommen könnte. Ich dachte, ich bin dieses Kind, aber bei diesem Kind, dem unterstellt man ja jetzt noch nicht irgendwelche sozialen, ich halte keine stillemäßigen Sachen, sondern wahrscheinlich ist einfach pures Interesse. Und aus dieser Stimme habe ich so viel pures Interesse gehört, dass ich dachte, wie schön ist das eigentlich? Kennt man als Erwachsener gar nicht mehr. Sodass einfach dann ein Mensch ist, der sich einfach sehr dafür interessiert, ob die ja häufig zum Brüsseler Platz gehen, ja oder nein, und wenn ja, wann? Ich muss das jetzt wissen. Ich will das wissen. Das Kind hat so laut gefragt, es wollte das jetzt wissen, ob die zum Brüsseler Platz häufig gehen. Weil das muss ja auch klar sein. Ja, weil das ist mein Lieblingsplatz, ich bin da gerne und möge den auch. Wir gehen da häufig hin, ihr etwa auch. Und das war so, ja, und das dachte ich mir, warum, wann verlieren das Erwachsene? Und können wir uns nicht darauf einigen, nur noch wirklich wichtige Fragen zu stellen über diesen belanglosen, musst du, dass du Schwachsinn? Vor allem ist es die beste Icebreaker-Frage. Viele fragen ja, gerade mich ja auch immer so, hey, wie machst du das eigentlich immer, Frauen ansprechen und so, wie schaffst du das? Und ich glaube, solche dummen Fragen sind die besten. Einfach, gehst du auch häufig zum Russlerplatz? Das ist ein bisschen wie ich Smalltalk führe, so Quatsch, wo bei Erwachsenen sagen einem dann, warum musst du das jetzt wissen? Oder callen dann so den Bluff. Aber bei dem Kind hat er dann ganz ehrlich auch geantwortet, was ich dann irgendwie schön fand. Ich denke mir manchmal Sachen aus, was ich von Beruf bin, wenn Leute mich fragen. Weil ich habe keinen Bock auf dieses, ich bin Moderator, Podcaster. Okay, was, wo, Internet, Fernsehen, gerade als so Ältere. Deswegen denke ich mir oft was aus. Meistens sage ich, ich bin Koch oder ich sage manchmal, ich bin Polizist. Weil die Leute dann oft so, ah, okay. Bei Polizisten habe ich gemerkt, gibt es leider oft zu viele Nachfragen. Das ist ein Problem. Aber mein Vorteil ist natürlich, dass ich jetzt durch How to Sell Drugs Bilder von mir in Polizeiuniformen habe. Das heißt, ich kann diese Lüge so ein bisschen untermauern, falls es wirklich mal dazu kommen würde. Und dann versuche ich einfach, das Gespräch möglichst schnell abzuwirken, einfach sagen, ja, ich möchte jetzt nicht über meine Arbeit sprechen, einfach so. Das ist sehr belastend. Du weißt schon, dass du auch bei deinem echten Job sagen kannst, dass du nicht über deine Arbeit sprechen willst. Ja, aber die Leute checken dann immer nicht, was das ist und dann so, ah, okay, verstehe ich nicht. Aber gut, dass du einen anderen Beruf wählst, wo mehr Rückfragen kommen, was das Problem ist. Ja, das hat streng genommen vergrößert. Ja, das stimmt schon. Tatsächlich, ich versuche auch langsam Polizisten aus meinem Repertoire raus zu sortieren. Vielleicht sage ich sowas, ich arbeite in Finanzen, sowas in der Richtung und dann fragt auch niemand nach, aber das ist auch zu interessant. Du bist Biologin, schreibst in Doktorarbeit Biologin, sorry, dass du darüber, dass du wie Pflanzen mit Hitze umgehen. Ja, und auf jede Nachfrage stelle ich, da weiß ich nicht, das habe ich nicht so gut.
Und alle sagen, der ist so clever,
der weiss so viel von dem Thema, der weiss nicht.
Habt ihr einen Beruf, dessen Nennung das Gespräch sofort im Keim erstickt?
Schreibt uns, das würde mich interessieren,
welcher Beruf ist ideal, um jedes Gespräch im Keim zu ersticken,
um einfach zu sagen, so, ah, was bist du für ein Beruf?
Ah, ich bin ein Beamter oder sowas.
Das sind wahrscheinlich so langweilig, so ein Vakuum, so sofort der Sauerstoff wird rausgepumpt aus dem Raum. Irgendliches Interesse wird aus dem Raum gesaugt. So, irgendliches Gesprächszündstoff wird aus dem Raum geschluckt. Ich kann jetzt übrigens auch über eine Sache sprechen, die ich seit den letzten Monaten gemacht habe, über die ich aber nicht öffentlich sprechen konnte. Und zwar, ich spiele Word of Warcraft. Ich bin viel weniger entspannt als noch vor einer Minute. Und Word of Warcraft ist ein Massive, ein Multiplayer-Spiel, wo man mit ganz vielen anderen Leuten zusammenspielt. Ich will das, was du mit Massive angefangen hast. Ein MMORPG, ein Massive Multiplayer Online Roleplay Game. Und da spielt man mit anderen Leuten zusammen und formiert sich oft in Gilden. Man muss dann in eine Gilde eintreten, man hat dann Namen, da gibt es dann Gildenleiter und Offiziere und so. Und dann macht man zusammen, tötet man dann den grossen Drachen. Und das heißt, wenn du spielst, musst du häufig in so eine Gilde gehen, um die grossen Ziele in einem Spiel zu erreichen. So, und ich war jetzt in einer Gilde, habe ich mich da einfach angemeldet und die haben
gesagt, sofort gesagt so, hey,
uns ist total wichtig, dass wir die
Leute auch kennenlernen, mit denen wir spielen
und wir machen morgen,
treffen wir uns im Discord, aber keine
WoW-Themen.
Oh,
ich dachte so, Gott, fuck.
Aber wie schlimm, dass du quasi der so der echten
Welt entfließt, in ein Spiel,
in dem Spiel dann so
sehr, so immersiv
Vielen Dank. dass du gehörst, fuck. Aber wie schlimm, dass du quasi der echten Welt entfließt,
in ein Spiel, in dem Spiel dann so sehr, so immersiv drin bist,
aber dass es dir eine echte Welt quasi reinholt.
Ja, genau.
Die auch wirklich gesagt haben, für uns ist nichts Schlimmeres,
als mit Leuten zusammen zu spielen, von denen wir nichts wissen. Wo er gesagt hat, nein, exakt das will ich,
mit Leuten zusammen zu spielen.
Das ist doch W.O.W., das ist doch Rollenspiel. Ja, du bist eine Nachtelfenpriesterin, du bist Dienerin der Elun, das reicht mir. Ich will nicht wissen, was du beruflich machst, du bist Beamtin, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Und dann dachte ich mir, nee, das kann ich nicht, ich kann nicht über mich da tatsächlich reden. So, jetzt wäre mein Impuls, ich weiß, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht dazu gekommen ist, mir eine andere Gilde zu suchen, die andere geflogen hat. Nee, meine ich nicht. Die Gilde war tatsächlich gut, weil die hatte gute Rate-Tage, wo ich Zeit hatte. Deswegen dachte ich mir, ich denke mir einfach eine Figur aus. Ich denke mir eine Figur aus, mit der ich immer in der Rolle bin, wenn ich in dieser Gilde aktiv bin. Und ich habe mir ein Textdokument aufgemacht und ich habe mir einen kompletten Fake-Lebenslauf geschrieben. Das heißt, du hast in diesem Rollenspiel, was du gespielt hast, noch eine andere Rolle. Aber jetzt frage ich mich, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu kompliziert. Aber hast du trotzdem als Florentin gespielt? Oder weil jetzt diese andere Figur dazwischen geschaltet ist, hast du quasi dein Spielverhalten auch aktiv geändert und eher als im Sinne der Figur gespielt.
Ja, absolut. Aber hat man dann als Florenti noch Spaß?
Nein, das ganze Projekt hat angefangen als, ich will sozialen Zwängen ausweichen und wurde ein nahezu lebensbestimmendes Nebenprojekt, weil ich habe mir diese Figur ausgedacht. Ich kann es sagen, Giacomo, ich war Giacomo. Nein. Mit Akzent? Mit Akzent, mit verstellter Stimme habe ich immer gesprochen und ich habe mir einen kompletten Lebenslauf geschrieben und irgendwann hatte ich so viel Spaß, da absurde Sachen in den Lebenslauf einzubauen, dass ich mir irgendwann zum Ziel gesetzt habe, wie viel Bullshit kann ich erzählen, bis die Leute sagen, du bist doch kein echter Mensch, du bist doch einfach nicht echt. Und deswegen habe ich irgendwann angefangen, meine Grundidee für die Figur. Ich möchte kurz vorweg greifen. Wieso kannst du jetzt darüber sprechen? Weil die Gilde sich aufgelöst hat. Die Gilde gibt es nicht mehr, damit stirbt auch die Figur Giacomo. Die Gilde gibt es nicht mehr und deswegen kann ich jetzt neu starten. Meine Grundidee für Giacomo war, dass er noch nie in seinem Leben Geld verdient hat. Er kriegt immer durch obskure, merkwürdige Zufälle Geld. Kramer quasi. Es ist ein bisschen wie Kramer. Und ich habe mir dann überlegt, verschiedene Punkte in dem Lebenslauf von Giacomo, wo ich, also erst habe ich erst als 16-jähriger Junge in dem Schwimmbad fast ertrunken. Er wurde da an so eine Ansaug, wo von den Becken das Wasser rausgesaugt wird, da ist er da hängen geblieben, wurde angesaugt und war fast ertrunken und hat von dem Schwimmbad 150.000 Euro Schadensersatz bekommen und dass er stillschweigt, dass er die nicht anklagt. Jetzt möchtest du das nochmal erzählen, diese Geschichte, aber mit dem Akzent von Giacomo. Nein, das meine ich nicht, das ist zu rassistisch, das tut mir leid. Giacomo, woher kommt Giacomo? Italienisch! Das haben wir von John Mulaney gelernt. Nein, von Pete Holmes haben wir das gelernt. Ach, von Pete Holmes, der einzige ... Peter Holmes, Peter Holmes, in der Zeit, Italienisch ist nicht schlimm. Das ist nicht schlimm, auch wenn man acht Oktaven hört. Ich frage mich, wann wird das schlimm? Wie karikiert muss man sprechen? Das geht nicht, glaube ich. Und das war die Grundidee für die Figur Giacomo. Kriegt ständig Geld, hat auch mal im Lotto gewonnen. Einfach dumm. Und ich habe überlegt, wie viel von diesen Storys kann ich einbauen in Gesprächen mit diesen Leuten aus der Gilde, bis sie sagen, es kann auch nicht wahr sein. Und der ist halt ein total langweiliger Typ, der sich immer auf die nebensächlichen Dinge konzentriert. Vor allem, es stehen ja zwei Dinge dem entgegen. Oder, oder eins, ich weiß nicht, ob ich diesen Satz jemals bis zum Ende war, aber also ... Ich hab vier Fragen. Ich hab ein paar Fragen. Wirklich? Nee, aber jetzt steht ja quasi der Glaubwürdigkeit der Überhöhung Giacomos entgegen, dass der viel, also es ist ja viel wahrscheinlicher, dass du einen weirden Charakter in der Gilde hast, der ein Lotto gewonnen hat, der überhöht, überhöht, überhöht, als jemanden, der das erfindet.
Das habe ich mir auch gedacht.
Und deswegen ist es nämlich nicht ein quasi repräsentatives Experiment so richtig.
Also du kannst nämlich daraus jetzt nicht gehen, das und das glauben dir Menschen, das kann damit kaum ein Mensch durchkommen, also will a character, sondern damit unter der Voraussetzung, dass da jemand ist, der sich das alles ausgedacht hat. Deswegen war es tatsächlich, irgendwann ist WoW nebensächlich geworden, sondern ich habe wirklich immer diese Figur aufgebaut und weitere Sachen eingestreut. Aber erzähl mal ganz kurz, um es zu verstehen, spielt man denn als die Figur dann per TeamSpeak oder sowas? Nein, nein, nein. Du bist der normale Spieler im TeamSpeak und sagt, hey, hat jemand einen Mannertrank für mich dabei? Jetzt lass uns den Boss legen und wo wartet der? Das heißt, aber wann warst du Giacomo? Wann warst du wirklich Giacomo? Wirklich halt im Voice-Chat. Wenn du im Voice-Chat bist, dann habe ich eine andere Rolle gespielt, eine andere Stimme und habe diese Figur dargestellt und habe auch immer wirklich immer auf einem Laptop neben mir mein Textdokument offen gehalten mit allen Sachen, um auch immer adäquat reagieren zu können. Falls mal irgendwelche Prüffragen kommen. Genau. Woher kommt noch seine Schwester nochmal Giacomo? Palermo! Palermo, aus dem sonnigen Palermo! Nein, so war es nicht, aber es war interessant und ich habe tatsächlich, glaube ich, das Gefühl gehabt, die haben mir alles geglaubt, vor allem ich habe so einen ganz langweiligen Charakter eigentlich gespielt, der aber dann immer unfassbare Sachen erlebt. Also er wirklich erzählt so, ja, also ich nehme ja immer, wenn ich zum Bus gehe, nehme ich 1,50 Euro mit, weil ich kaufe mir dann immer so einen Croissant-Hotdog und also ich packe dann zu Hause bei mir immer schon 1,50 Euro ein und gehe dann zur Bushaltestelle und während ich warte, kaufe ich mir so einen Croissant-Hotdog, aber jetzt wurde der Preis runtergesetzt von den Croissant-Hotdogs auf 1,30 Euro, aber ich vergesse das morgens immer und ich nehme also schon 1,50 Euro mit und kaufe mir dann den Croissant-Hotdog und dann habe ich aber 20 Cent übrig, die tue ich dann in die andere Hosentasche. Und dann denke ich mir, am nächsten Tag habe ich wieder vergessen, dass es 1,30 Euro kostet.
Und dann habe ich wieder 20 Cent zu viel, tue es wieder in die andere Tasche.
Und irgendwann hatte ich 10 Euro in 20 Cent-Stücken in einer Tasche.
Und dann dachte ich mir, Giacomo, was machst du jetzt?
Dann dachte ich mir, ah, bei dem Kiosk, wo ich immer diese Croissant-Hotdogs kaufe, kann man sich ein Lotto-Ticket kaufen für zehn Euro. Dann dachte ich, ja, ich habe jetzt genau die zwanzig Cent-Stücke für zehn Euro da. Dann habe ich mir ein Lotto-Ticket gekauft und 260.000 Euro gewonnen. Aber ich nehme immer noch 1,50 Euro mit für die Croissant-Hotdogs. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jemals lerne. Und jetzt habe ich immer 20 Cent-Stücke dabei. Und ich weiß nicht, ich denke mir, soll ich mir einen Wecker stellen morgens, dass da steht, Giacomo denkt dran, die kosten nur 1,30 Euro. Und alle im Voice so, du hast 260.000 Euro gewonnen. Giacomo geht, aber auch gute Zahl übrigens, die glaubt man eher als 52.000. Lottogewinne sind immer so strange. Aber auch gut von, also Giacomo ist der Charakter, der geht über die spannenden Details weg. Genau. Wie man Kuppel von mir, der langweilige Geschichten erzählt, der Kerl, aber manchmal fragt man sich, warum hast du das jetzt erzählt? Nichts daran ist erzählenswert, niemals würde man diese Geschichte normalerweise erzählen, aber Giacomo packt dann da drin plötzlich Dinge, die extrem waren. Mein Ziel war immer, dass die anderen Leute nachfragen müssen, sorry, habe ich das gerade richtig gehört, was, dass sie mit diesem Charakter interagieren müssen und es war sehr, sehr lustig tatsächlich, war großartig und das ist halt diese langweilige Figur, die halt darüber redet, wie sie entscheidet, ob sie morgens eine Regenjacke mitnimmt oder nicht, aber halt auch mal mit einer Frau von einem russischen Oligarchen geschlafen hat.
Und damit die Ehe nicht kaputt geht, hat sie ihm 260.000 Euro gezahlt. War es immer 260.000? Nein, nein, hat sie ihm 260.000 Euro gezahlt. Und damit er das Geld waschen kann, hat er so eine Telefonerotikfirma gegründet und hat dann so ein Callcenter aufgebaut mit einem Kumpel von ihm und einfach ganz viele Einnahmen behauptet, um das Geld zu waschen. Aber er erzählt die Geschichte halt primär dadurch, dass sie sich überlegt haben, welche Stühle sie für das Callcenter bestellen wollen und dann den Stuhl wieder zurückgegeben haben. Wie viel hat Giacomo bekommen damals, als das eine Freibad war? Ich glaube, das waren weniger, das waren 160 Oder 60.000. Wenn es immer die gleiche Summe wäre. Aber hast du Hinweise gestreut, die Leute aufahnen lassen, hätten lassen können, die gesagt haben, ach, das ist gefakt? Ich weiß es nicht, also ja natürlich schon, also wie gesagt, dass die Preise immer ähnlich sind, dass die Geschichten immer wilder werden, dass seine Hobbys super strange sind. Er sucht das Bernsteinzimmer, das ist sein Hobby, weil er kann sich immer so ein bisschen Zeit rausnehmen, also gleich ein Hobby wie meine Mutter. Weird. Merkwürdig. Insane. Aber es ist teilweise auch verrückt, wo Leute nicht nachfragen, was Leute einfach so hinnehmen. Also entweder interessiert es sich nicht oder sie nehmen es einfach hin, weil ich habe auch geschrieben, an dem ersten Tag, als sie in der Gilde war, was ich immer den besten Satz fand, wenn man neu in die Gilde kommt, ist, ich wurde ja aus meiner letzten Gilde wurde ich herausgeschmissen. Und dann hat dann schon der Gilde leider mal nachgefragt, so warum wurdest du denn aus der Gilde herausgeschmissen? Ich habe geschrieben, ja, wegen meinem Opa. Und da kam dann keine Nachfrage mehr. Das hat niemand nachgefragt. Das wurde so hingenommen als ... Okay. Okay, gut. Dann versuchen wir es mit dir. Wenn es an deinem Opa lag, versuchen wir es. Ja, weil man kann sich darunter jetzt nichts mehr Schlimmes vorstellen. Ja, aber ich dachte schon, dass du dann nachfragen, aber ich wusste halt auch nicht gewusst, was ich da drauf sagen würde, aber jetzt kann ich es dir sagen, Giacomo ist offiziell gestorben, das Projekt ist beendet, ich habe noch seitenlang einen komplett ausgebauten Lebenslauf für diesen Menschen gebaut. Aber ich finde es ist traurig. Ich bin mittlerweile mehr Giacomo als ich selber, ich weiß mehr über Giacomo als für mich. Ich behaupte, du bist auch immer schon ein bisschen mehr Giacomo gewesen, vielleicht als Florentin. Ja, kann auch sein. Aber jetzt die Frage, ist Giacomo wirklich tot oder gibt es da nochmal ein Revival? Also gerade das mit der Stimme verstellen war im Laufe der Zeit schon arg nervig. Weil immer wenn du halt in der Gilde spielst. Du kannst ihn auch Günther nennen und in Deutsch sprechen lassen. Ja genau, aber das war schon echt nervig, das mache ich vielleicht beim nächsten Mal anders.
Oder ich hole mir halt so einen Voice-Computer, der dann halt immer so richtig tief oder richtig hoch macht oder sowas in der Richtung.
Einen Stimmenverzerrer.
Einen Stimmenverzerrer, was ich auch witzig finde.
Oder dann auch immer so mit Geräuschen.
Ich habe dann auch immer Musik eingespielt, das fand ich ja am allerlustigsten.
Im Voice habe ich Musik eingespielt, also dass du halt Spotify anmachst und dann den Audiokanal halt so legst, dass es auch ins Voice geht, mit deiner Stimme zusammen. Santa Maria. Von Seal Rose. Halt diesen Song und den habe ich halt mitten im superintensiven Bosskämpfen mittendrin halt einfach angemacht, diesen Song, den alle im Voice gehört haben, wo niemand erstmal, wo kommt diese scheiß Musik her, macht die Musik auch. auch am Ende des Films Giacomo eine Reise irgendwie, aber auch dann Leute sagen würden, wir brauchen
jetzt, wenn Giacomo gestorben ist und die
dann aber nochmal kämpfen, aber wir brauchen jetzt
kann irgendwer Kiss from a Rose anmachen
wir brauchen ein Ziel, wir brauchen jetzt, wenn Giacomo gestorben ist und die dann aber nochmal kämpfen, aber wir brauchen jetzt, kann irgendwer Kiss from a Rose anmachen, wir brauchen ein Ziel, wir brauchen ein Ziel. Und was irgendwie sympathisch ist, dass sie immer daran gewöhnen sind, Ziel läuft. Ja, und einfach immer die Musik und immer so, oh sorry, ich wusste jetzt nicht, oh Entschuldigung, ich wusste nicht, dass sie das auch hört, ich höre das privat. Und immer derselbe Song, in jedem Rate mehrmals derselbe Song, dieser Mensch hört nur einen Song, nur einen. Ah, das war schon witzig, aber einen guten, einen besten Song. Richtig guter Song, richtig guter Song, kann ich mich richtig gut anhören und ich habe den Song in der Zeit so oft gehört, weil ich den immer angestaltet habe, wann ihn die anderen auch hören, zu den unpassenden Momenten, wenn der Rate-Lied dann einfach sagt, ey Leute, das kann das nicht sein, Ihr könnt nicht einfach 20 Minuten zu spät kommen, wir müssen alle arbeiten.
Aber kommt der Song immer,
hören alle ...
Ja, ist ein grossartiger Song.
Haben alle gehört, die im Voice waren,
alle in dem Chat.
Ist der Song, den ich mir immer laut vorsinge,
um pinkeln zu können, im Pissoir neben anderen Leuten. Echt? Hat das jetzt was ausgelöst bei dir gerade, den zu singen? Pinkeln, ich musste pinkeln, ja. Ja, wurde an mich herangetragen von jemandem, der das aber krasser hatte als ich, das Problem. Und dann immer sehr laut in seinem Kopf Kiss from a Rose. Aber du singst nur in deinem Kopf. Laut in deinem Kopf. Ja, der ist sehr laut, er hat so beschrieben. Da muss ich sehr laut. Du musst dir quasi die Ohren auch zuhalten, was so laut ist in deinem Kopf. Und dann summe ich immer vor mich hin Kiss from a Rose. Ein grandioser Song. Perfekt. Ohnehin Ziel kann man immer hören. Geht so. Dies diesem einen Song bin ich eher skeptisch. Ja, aber das ist ja unterscheidend, das ist das grösste Experiment, soziale Experiment, auch gerade in Zeiten von Catfishing und so. Irre Relektions. Ja, ich finde es schade, dass es so abrupt abgebrochen ist, weil ich noch viele Sachen geplant habe. Und dass niemand davon, niemand das mitbekommen hat, ausser du jetzt, oder gab es da ein grosses Making-of, Giacomo, How It Started. Nee, gar nicht, das erste Mal, dass ich darüber rede, und ich bin sehr stolz auf den Charakter, jetzt werden es noch ein paar richtig coole Sachen gekommen, die ich jetzt noch nicht verraten will, weil vielleicht benutzt ihr das noch. Meine Idee war dann auch, dass er irgendwann von unterwegs spielt, weil wir hatten tatsächlich mal jemanden in der Gilde, der Lkw-Fahrer war, der während dem Fahren World of Warcraft gespielt hat und in unserem Voice war. Oder jetzt rückblickend war das auch Bullshit. Kann auch Bullshit gewissen sein, ja. Weil das steht ja auch alles in Feier. Mittlerweile traue ich gar nichts mehr, denn er meinte so, oh Leute, okay, Rackle-Dos, okay, ich muss mal rechts ranfahren. Also, was? Du fährst gerade Auto mit einem Lkw? Und dann habe ich mir eben auch geliebt, dass Jacko auch mal unterwegs ist, weil er ist auf der Suche nach einem Bernsteinzimmer und ist dann irgendwie auf dem Schiff oder im Zelt im Wald oder irgendwie sowas und hat so ein Satellitentelefon, um WoW spielen zu können und wird dann von einem Wolf angegriffen oder irgendwie sowas. Das habe ich mir alles überlegt, konnte ich aber alles nicht umsetzen leider. Und dann verklagt er den Wolf und kriegt 260.000 Euro und kann wieder ein bisschen überleben. Aber auch diese vielen Geschichten, die du den Leuten da draußen geschenkt hast, die jetzt natürlich die coolsten Leute in ihrem jeweiligen Freundeskreis sind, weil die halt die besten Geschichten haben. Wie viele Menschen da draußen reden über diesen weirden Giacomo aus ihrer Gilde bei WoW, den sie kennen. und wahrscheinlich hast du viele schöne Abende bereitet. Ja.
Und ich dachte gerade, diesen weirden Giacomo aus ihrer Gilde bei W.O.W., den sie kennen. Und
wahrscheinlich hat das so viele schöne Abende bereitet.
Und ich dachte gerade,
das ist wahrscheinlich das grösste
coole Experiment, wo niemand
was von mitbekommt. Aber ich glaube schon,
dass sehr viele was von mitbekommen. Kann schon sein. Ich habe
auch einmal gesungen, weil ich habe gesagt
Giacomo und dann
meine ich auch, ja, meine Mutter hat mich benannt, die ist
großer Opernfan nach Giacomo Rossini und die hat mich auch gezwungen, Gesangsunterricht zu nehmen, aber ich wollte das gar nicht und dann alle so, ah okay und dann meinte so, ja, ich könnte euch ja mal was vorsingen, wenn wir den Boss legen, singe ich euch was vor und alle so, ja, okay, Oh mein Gott, das ist krimpig. Ich habe den Pass gegeneinander, ich habe das vorgesungen. Was habe ich gesungen?
Kiss from a Rose natürlich. Ha, ne, kiss from a rose. Und das hat halt wirklich lange gedauert, weil ich habe den Refang absichtlich viel zu oft gesungen, einfach damit die Leute auch nicht reinsagen können, dass die Leute sagen, okay, reicht jetzt, wir können weiter. Es ist Ray-Tag, wir wollen noch ein paar Bosse legen. Ach Gott, aber ich glaube schon, dass ... Bist du mal gebraked? Ich bin gebraked, aber ich konnte mich ja immer muten und so. Das hat ja gut funktioniert. Aber ich glaube schon, dass es Leute da draußen gibt, die erzählen, wir hatten da jemanden in der Gilde, der dann gesungen, nachdem Boss getötet wurde. Aber würdest du sagen, du hast Freunde gefunden als Giacomo? Ich nicht, aber Giacomo. Nee, hat Giacomo Freunde gefunden. Giacomo hat, glaube ich, echt Freunde gefunden, weil tatsächlich reagieren Leute sehr gut auf so exzentrische Figuren, die einfach wilde Sachen erzählen. Und da kann jeder was dazu erzählen. Und die Leute erzählen dann auch was irgendwie über sich, was weirdes, was immer passiert ist. Wenn du mal diesen Icebreaker hast, weil niemand wird weirder sein als Giacomo. Egal, was du für verrückte Sachen erzählst, über dich preisgibst. Giacomo ist immer der Weirdo. Aber der setzt halt den Rahmen so. Alles, was unter seinem Weirdness-Level ist, kann man erzählen. Und dann erzählen sich die Leute Sachen, weil es irgendwie so eine Art Safe Space geworden ist. Weil es ist eh niemand bescheuerter als er. deswegen auf eine weirde Art lockert man so die Leute Sachen, weil es irgendwie so eine Art ja, Safe Space geworden ist, weil es ist eh niemand bescheuerter als er. Deswegen, auf eine weirde Art lockert man so die Leute auch auf und kriegt auch aus den Leuten Sachen raus. Ich weiß nicht, wie es normalerweise ist, aber hält man Kontakt zu seinen ehemaligen Gildenmitgliedern? Wenn schon sehr intensiv ist es manchmal. Es gibt ja auch Gilden, die sich dann im Real Life treffen und so. Halten denn Leute Kontakt noch zu Giacomo? Also wollten Leute nach dem Bisher nicht, bisher nicht. Ich weiß noch nicht genau, was in der Gilde vorgefallen ist. Mehr als die Hälfte der Leute haben ihren Account gelöscht und die Gilde ist aufgelöst worden. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so eine Art Razzia oder ob die alle mich verarscht haben. Nee, ich glaube, das klingt gerade so, als ob alle diesen Weirdo loswerden wollen und jetzt so fingiert haben.
So WhatsApp-Gruppen verweisen lässt
und auflöst, nur damit du eine neue
ohne den anderen machst. Und wie du auch nicht checkst,
dass die alle, die ganze Gilde für sich,
aber die können die einfach rausschmeißen.
Ja, können sie schon, aber das würde ich halt merken, das würde ich halt sehen,
dass sie rausgeschmissen werden.
Accounts löschen klingt schon so,
als ob die das jetzt nicht faken können, oder?
Nee, nicht so leicht. Aber das ist schon echt ein Commitment, nochmal einen neuen Charakter hochzuspielen. Aber ich finde, schade, ich dachte gerade, als du meine, dass Jakob und Freunde gefunden, dass sie jetzt auch noch irgendwie sich um ihn kümmern und so. Bisher nicht, nee. Es kann schon sein, dass ich verstoßen wurde und sie auf einem anderen, vielleicht sind sie auf einem anderen Server oder so. Ich glaube, das geht gar nicht in dem WoW, das ich spiele, dass man Server wechselt. Aber kann sein. Aber hast du da was für dein echtes Leben mitgenommen? Also wenn du gerade schon sagst, Leute, die exzentrischer sind, werden gut aufgenommen. Warum bist du nicht exzentrischer? Warum nicht mal, wo geht die Geschichten erzählen oder so offener sein? Erst mal so, dass die Herz auf die Zunge tragen. Ich habe tatsächlich gelernt, man kann leichter mit Leuten connecten. Merkwürdigerweise, wenn man lügt, wenn man einfach Bullshit erzählt, Lügen erzählt, man connectet leichter. Nicht das Learning, auf das ich hinaus will. Weil man die Leute einfach auflockert und auch wenn die anderen auch lügen, ich glaube, man kann mehr man selbst sein, wenn man eine Maske trägt. So ist es auch mit Giacomo. Du kannst schon was von dir selber in die Rolle tun, wenn es bei den anderen ankommt und auch so zurückkommt. Also es kann schon sein. Es ist schon merkwürdig, aber noch kam nichts zurück, also mal schauen, wie es weitergeht. Ja, schade, es darf nicht so vorbei sein, finde ich. Also ich finde, Giacomo muss weiterleben. Mal schauen, was sich in der nächsten Gilde macht, bin da momentan wieder auf der Suche, was ja wirklich, wie so ein Bewerbungs, bei manchen Gilden hast du wirklich so ein Bewerbungsgespräch, wo du dann in so ein Chatroom gehst und dann musst du sagen, was hast du schon so gemacht, wie viel spielst du so? Ja, also ich weiß auch nicht, ich spiele jetzt seit ich zwölf bin und ich bin Priester. Wie nervig. Und du bist schon ein echter Mensch oder verarscht du mich gerade? Nein, nein, also ich bin schon echt. Aber suchen wir bestimmt doch auch, ich möchte weiter Giacomo haben. Weil ich finde es doch auch fantastisch, wenn du jetzt einer anderen großen Gilde beitrittst und dann kommen da Leute, die den schon kennen und so. Kann auch passieren, ja. Kann auch passieren. Weil ich habe immer einen Charakternamen. Der Charaktername bleibt ja immer gleich. Das heißt, die Leute können schon merken ... Das wäre merkwürdig. Wenn ich nicht jemand anders bin, das wäre natürlich schon merkwürdig. Wenn ich jetzt eine andere Figur Leute, die Leute kennen dich ja vielleicht in der neuen Gilde. Aber ich habe für die Figur auch echt recherchiert. Also ich habe mir schon Gedanken gemacht, auch so Geldwäsche und so, wie würde man das ungefähr machen? Jetzt nicht im Detail, aber dass ich jetzt dann nicht, weil es kann ja sein, dass da Leute in der Gilde sind, die halt irgendwie BWL-Studie haben oder so, die sofort den Bluff callen, wenn ich erzähle, wie ich Geldwäsche gemacht habe, wenn das halt völlig unrealistisch ist. Aber ich mir dachte, so ein Callcenter, so Erotik-Hotline ist gar nicht so schlecht, weil niemand kann ja genau nachvollziehen, wie viele Leute da jeden Tag anrufen und du sagst einfach, wir haben so viel Geld verdient. Oder Pizzeria. Ja, oder Pizzeria, aber gut, ich kann es nicht einfach lernen, wie man Pizza kocht, zu behaupten, man hätte so eine Erotik-Hotline, das kann ja quasi jeder.
Bei Giacomo ist das bestimmt in der Familie.
Kann ja quasi jeder, aber das habe ich mir
schon überlegt und dann auch diese ganzen
Sachen mit dem russischen Oligarchen
und kann man einfach so Geld geschenkt
bekommen als Erpressung, wenn dich
jemand erpresst oder wenn dich jemand
besticht eher, hier du kriegst
260.000 Euro, wie geht das?
Wird das einfach auf dein Konto überwiesen?
Fragt das Finanzamt dann, was ist das? Und du sagst,
da wurde ich bestochen. Muss man das
Das ist ein Schuss. Besticht eher, hier du kriegst 260.000 Euro, wie geht das? Wird das einfach auf dein Konto überwiesen? Fragt das Finanzamt dann, was ist das? Und du sagst, da wurde ich bestochen. Muss man das dann versteuern? Oder muss man dann einfach alles zurückgeben? Wenn du mich jetzt erwischst, wie ich fremdgehe und ich sage, ich gebe dir 260.000 Euro, du sagst niemandem was davon. Was erzählst du deinem Steuerberater? Kannst du dann dem wirklich sagen, ja, ich wurde bestochen, gibt es eine Bestätigungssteuer oder ist es völlig illegal? Man muss es zurückgeben. Ich glaube, ich kann es nicht absetzen, ehrlich gesagt, weil es nicht gegenüber meinem Beruf steht. Es ist keine berufliche Ausgabe. Einkommen, ja. Nee, wenn ich dir das Diabels überweise. Ach, okay. Und du musst es aber, glaube ich, ganz normal versteuern als Einkommen. Als Einkommen einfach, ganz normal.
Aber ich habe eher das Gefühl, dass ich bei diesem steuerlichen Ding gegen die Wand rede. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich mir dran diese Bühne gebe. Das lassen wir lieber. Nee, das ist kein Geist. Aber ist dir aufgefallen, wie Mühe ich mir gegeben habe, dir nochmal genau aufzudröseln, wie du es in Zukunft machen sollst? Das ist nett. Du versuchst das immer so ein bisschen nebenbei mir beizubringen, wie man Steuern zahlt. Ja, aber es ist wenig Eigeninteresse, wenig, wenig Altruismus und mehr Eigeninteresse, weil wir zusammen auch als Tietze Willgebe eher gemeinsam haften und dann im Boot hängen. Meinst du nicht, wenn ich im Gefängnis wäre, würde der Podcast weitergehen, vielleicht sogar interessanter werden? Ja. Ich stelle mir halt dann immer so vor, wie man so eine große Gefängnismauer sieht, wo so ein schwarzes Kabel drüber geht und ich im Gefängnissitz und du hast mir so das Mikro rüber geworfen. Das berühmte Podcast-Kabel, das schwarze, was man kennt. Du hast mir so das Mikrofon über die Mauer geworfen, in mein Fenster rein, ich fange die auf, wir sind am Handy. Wir machen das so Shawshank Redemption-mäßig, kriegst du quasi, oder war es doch mal nicht, wo du kriegst so in Sachen, die verbacken und so, kriegst du die Einzelteile von Mikros. Das stimmt. Und am Ende kannst du dein Mikro zusammenbauen. Ja, das finde ich richtig gut. Einfach wie so ein Dürüm, wo einfach so dieses Mikrofon drin ist. Ja, genau, aber erst mal nur so die Membran, was auch immer. Ja, das finde ich schlecht. Und am Ende kannst du dir das zusammenbauen, dann kriegst du noch ein XLR-Kabel geschickt, in einem Lasso. Er liebt Cowboys. Das war ein Lasso eher. Ich glaube ganz ehrlich, du könntest einfach podcasten aus dem Knast. Ich glaube, das ist in Deutschland kein Ding. Gibt es auch hundertprozentig schon? Wir müssen mal aufhören. Knastcast? Podknast? Podknast. Wir müssen mal aufhören, mal so zu denken, als wären wir hier in den USA oder so. Auch wieder so ein Ding, Filme diktieren uns in unsere Wir Wirklichkeit ist ja nicht so. Deutsche Knasts sind wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig entspannt.
Knästen sind wahnsinnig komfortabel.
Aber Leute sind es aber auch nicht so komfortabel,
dass man unbedingt hin will, also immer noch.
Doch, ganz ehrlich für dich.
Rechtsstaat, wir würden schon gerne, haltet euch bitte an Gesetze,
das hat schon seinen Ziel. Ich glaube, dass die mehr Möbel haben in ihrem Zimmer als du.
Ja, definitiv. Wirklich. Mehr Teppiche, glaube ich auch. Ich glaube, ja. Null Teppiche, null. Gar nichts. Einen Teppich habe ich, zwei. Nee, ich habe überhaupt keine Teppiche. Mag ich beide nicht mehr. Ich weiß nicht, wo man Teppiche herbekommt, in gut, bezahlbar. Kriegt man die, glaube ich, nicht hin. Also so schöne Teppiche, die sich so einigermaßen wertig anfühlen. Haut mal eure Teppichlieferanten raus, nichts gefunden, was gut aussieht und auch nicht schweineteuer. Nee, keine Ahnung. Aber ich glaube, ich würde weitermachen im Knast, einfach schön. Ich glaube, man könnte dann natürlich sehen, wie ich mich weiterentwickele als Mensch im Knast, natürlich so ein bisschen rauer werde. Hätte ich aber auch Bock drauf, glaube ich, einfach mal so ein bisschen Rauheit zu lernen.
Deine Giacomo-Learnings kannst du ja überall anwenden.
Jetzt quasi überall, wenn man einen neuen Lebensabschnitt betritt oder sowas.
Niemand im Knast kennt Florentin Will.
Du kannst ja da auch du selbst sein.
Du kannst ja auch sagen, du überlegst dir eine Rolle.
Und bist halt dann nicht Giacomo, sondern Florentin,
aber halt hast trotzdem die TXT-Dateien auf mit der neuen DNA.
Weil warum nicht, also warum nicht häufiger mal jemand anders sein?
Ich finde auch, also klar, es gibt bestimmt Leute da draußen, die mich jetzt verunglimpfen, dass ich Leute angelogen habe, aber um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich glaube, ich meine, wenn du ein Spiel spielst, es ist doch interessanter, mit interessanten Leuten zusammenzuspielen, als mit dem hundertsten langweiligen, ja, ich bin Student und ich studiere Bauingenieurwesen, haben nichts zu erzählen, haben nichts zu erleben, als jemand, der sagt, ich habe mit einer russischen Oligarchenfrau geschlafen, die mich bestochen hat und ich musste das Geld irgendwie waschen und das war ziemlich verrückt und dann habe ich aber das russische Bussystem nicht verstanden und dann bin ich immer falsch eingestiegen in den Bus.
Wir wollen mehr von der Summe wissen!
Dann bin ich da ausgestiegen und dann wusste ich nicht, wo ich bin und konnte ja auch nicht nachfragen,
weil ich spreche nur Tschechisch, aber die werden sauer, wenn man Tschechisch mit denen spricht,
das ist wirklich wie ein Affront und naja, dann bin ich auf jeden Fall in den Bus noch mal eingestiegen
und dann bin ich aber, war ich wo ganz woanders plötzlich, da war alles grau
und dann dachte ich mir, ich frage meinen Polizisten, stellt sich raus, es waren Postbote, habe ich gesagt, kann ich mich selber irgendwo hinschicken. Ich liebe Giacomo, dieses unfokussierte Erzählen, nicht wissen, aber es ist auch realistisch. Mir passiert so viel weirder Shit, dass er den weirden Shit selber gar nicht mehr so weird wahrnimmt.
Genau, das ist für ihn für dich normal. Er geht drüber hinweg. Ja, der hat noch nie einen Job gehabt, der verdient sein ganzes Leben lang Geld mit so irgendeinem random, merkwürdigen Bestechungs-Schadensersatz weirden Sachen. Da findet er diesen Fakt, dass er immer was von sie Cent in der Tasche hat, einfach spannender, als diesen Fakt again, 260.000 geschenkt zu bekommen. Ja. Nee, aber ich dachte gerade, wo du meintest, du hast immer so ein Dokumentaufruf gehabt, falls Rückfragen kommen. Das hätte ich gern für mich als Stefan. Ja, total. Wo alles drinsteht, was du schon mal gesagt hast. Wo du schon mal improvisiert hast. Ich behaupte, ich improvisiere täglich. Ich behaupte täglich irgendeinen Quatsch. Ich hätte gern ein Dokument, wo einfach etwas drinsteht. Und wenn Rückfragen kommen, kommen wir mittlerweile meistens Gott sei Dank schriftlich. Ja. Da kann man da ein bisschen scrollen und gucken. Danke, dass ihr weniger Sprachnachrichten sendet. Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank. Also dann denke ich mir, das kriegt man da hin. Aber das ist interessant. Aber so sehr habe ich selber noch nicht mir eingestanden, eine Rolle zu spielen. Wir spielen alle nur einen Tag. Das ist ja Quatsch, zu behaupten, wir werden alle authentische. Wobei ich verstehe schon, da wird ein bisschen Gegenwind kommen, aber ich finde im Sinne des Experiments ist das durchaus erlaubt. Du bist dann nicht bei keiner Dating-Plattform gewesen oder sowas, oder Leute haben ernsthafte Beziehungen zu dir aufbauen wollen, sondern es war ja diese doch anonyme Gilde. Ich glaube, aber es gibt ja viele soziale Anlässe, die wirklich unerträglich sind, wo man muss irgendwie jemanden zu so einem Yoga-Kurs begleiten oder irgendeine Party, wo man nicht hingehen will. Ich glaube, man kann ab einem Wissenpunkt einfach sagen, ich bullshitte mich durch den Abend durch. Es macht mehr Spaß und ich glaube, auch die anderen haben mehr Spaß, weil die anderen haben ja auch kein echtes Interesse an dir, sondern du kannst einfach bullshitten. Du kannst einfach sagen. Gehst du auch häufiger zum Brüsseler Platz? Ja, das Kind würde ich nicht anlügen. Da würde ich sagen, nein, ich hasse den Brüsselerplatz.
Das ist der schlechteste Platz von ganz Köln. Nur Idioten sind auf dem Brüsselerplatz. Weißt du, wo Brüssel ist?
Nein.
Aha, ist keine Ahnung vom Brüsselerplatz.
Nein, mein Bruder, meine Mama und ich sind häufig am Brüsselerplatz.
Ist dein Bruder wirklich dein Bruder?
Ja.
Woher weißt du das?
Mama gesagt. Mhm. Hat Mama schon mal gelogen? Nein, Erwachsene lügen nie. Dann lass mich dir die Geschichte von Giacomo erzählen. Komm mit, komm mit, Kind, Kleinkind, komm mit, ich nehme dich mit und führe dich durch Köln alleine, weg von deiner Mama, hin zu Giacomo. Ja, also mal schauen, was daraus wird. Das Dokument ist offen, ich werde es weiter ausarbeiten. Vielleicht wird auch ein Roman draus oder ein Podcast, keine Ahnung, die Abenteuer von Giacomo. Auf der Suche nach Giacomo. Auf der Suche nach Giacomo. Searching Giacomo. Being Giacomo finde ich eigentlich mega. Being Giacomo. Also mal schauen und Ich finde es eine tolle Doku. Ja, eigentlich schon, ne? Ja, ich finde es eine fantastische Dokumentation. Habe ich jetzt halt alles nicht dokumentiert, ne? Ja, das war, aber du hast vielleicht geübt für die Doku, die du irgendwann mal rausbringst. Muss ich nochmal loslegen. Naja, haut rein. Haut rein, macht's gut, habt eine schöne Woche. Habt eine wunderschöne Woche, nehmt ernst, habt eine schöne Woche, entspannt euch, geht wählen und lasst es krachen.
Was wünschst du den Leuten, ist es wirklich eine schöne Woche oder hast du dir das ein Dokument aufgeschrieben, das den Leuten eine schöne Woche wünschen muss?
Nein, ach Quatsch, nein. Was bist noch du?
Nein, ich bin hier, ich bin echt und ich wünsche euch eine echt schöne Woche, macht's gut, bis dann, wie eben ab, ciao.
Wie eben ab, ciao, macht's gut.
It's the worse bird production.